some students want to know what gets
used up in an incandescent lightbulb
when it is in series with a resistor
current energy or both they come up with
the following two questions in one
second to do fewer electrons leave the
bulb then enter the bulb and does the
electric potential energy of electrons
change while inside the bulb so this
first question is really a measure of
current because current is how much
charge per second is going through a
particular part of our circuit so charge
per second is what you could also think
of electrons per second so currents
going to measure the first one and the
electric potential energy of the
electrons well that's going to be
voltage does the voltage change is there
a voltage drop when we go from one side
of the bulb to another the students have
an adjustable power source insulated
wire lightbulbs resistors switches volt
meters and meters in other standard lab
equipment assume the power supply in
volt meters are marked in intense of a
volt increments and a meters are marked
in hundredths of an amp increments all
right describe an experimental procedure
that could be used to answer questions
one and two above in your description
state the measurements you would make
and how you would use equipment to make
them include a neat labeled diagram of
your setup all right so let's do Part A
right over here so I have so Part A so
we're going to have a power source and I
think they said it was a variable power
source did they say that they say yeah
the students have the students have an
adjustable power source insulated wire
lightbulbs resistor switches and volt
meters and they wanted to know an
incandescent bulb light bulb when it is
in series with a resistor so an
incandescent light bulb when it is in
series with the resistor so let's make
an attempt at drawing this so just the
circuit the circuit only that they care
about we could do our adjustable power
source so let me draw that so you could
do that like this make a couple I'll do
a couple here so like this
so that would be a power source where
this is the positive end this is the
negative end and then let me make my
circuit before any measurement tools
then we'll add the measurement tools so
I'm going to make it in series with a
resistor so let's put a resistor a
resistor here of some resistance and
then let's keep going with our circuit
so we're going to keep going with our
circuit and I'll let's put our
incandescent light bulb and the symbol
for an incandescent light bulb there's
actually several I'll use this one where
I do a little bump here and then I'll
continue in August you're going to put a
circle around that bump so it would be
just like I'm almost there I'm trying to
it neatly because they're telling us to
do it with a neat diagram all right let
me draw it a little bit better than that
so it would look something like this and
then let me put a circle around this so
putting a circle around this this is our
incandescent light bulb this is our
power source and to show it's a variable
power source I can put an arrow across
it like this that shows us that it is a
variable power source so this is a
circuit that I've just set up but I want
to use some ammeters and voltmeters in
order to measure what's happening as as
our electrons are going through the
lightbulb and the standard convention is
to show current going from the positive
terminal to the negative terminal but we
know and if you don't know I encourage
you to watch the Khan Academy videos on
it what's actually happening is you have
electrons traveling from the negative
terminal to the positive one but in
general if we just wanted to talk about
the current you would denote it the
current would the convention is that the
puck the current goes from the positive
direction to the negative direction you
could view it as there the positive gaps
of electrons or however you want to but
the electrons are actually moving in the
other direction so the first question is
do you have a different number of
electrons moving per second before
entering the lightbulb then when you
come out of the lightbulb well the way
you can measure that is by measuring the
current on either side of the lightbulb
and the way we can measure the current
on either side of the lightbulb is we
can insert we can insert a meters
on either side and ammeters have to be
inserted in series so giving them some
space so I can insert my and meters so
that is one ammeter it's going to
measure current right through that part
so I'll put a there and then that is
another ammeter right over there and
meter so these are going to measure
current on either side of our light bulb
so current measures current on either
side on either or I could say measuring
current entering and exiting light bulb
current entering and exiting and exiting
the light bulb entering the light bulb
or I'll just save me by saying and
exiting the bulb and we also care about
the voltage drop so we could put a
voltmeter and the voltmeter can be put
in parallel with a light bulb so let me
draw the voltmeter here so I'm trying to
draw it neatly so this is the voltmeter
and it's going to measure the voltage
drop from one side from one side to
another to connect this right over K so
this measures the voltage drop measures
measures voltage measures voltage drop
so I've done my diagram we'll see what
else 22 do so they say describe an
experimental procedure that could be
used to answer questions 1 & 2 above in
your description state the measurements
you would make and how you would use
equipment to make them include a neat
label diagram of your setup ok
so I guess my description I could say
I'd put put 2 ammeters
m meters in series in series with
bulb 1 1 before bulb bulb right bulb 1
after one after if current same on both
then same number of electrons entering
and exiting bulb if the current current
is the same the same on either side
either side then then electrons per
second entering and exiting will be the
same entering and exiting the same if
the currents are different if the
currents are different then the rate of
electrons is different then rate of
electrons passing are different are
different alright so that's the first
part the first statement to try to go
for this first statement for statement
one in one second do fewer electrons
leave the bulb then enter the bulb if
the ammeters are measuring the same
current well then you have the same
number of electrons per second entering
and leaving the bulb if the ammeter
measures different currents well then
you get different numbers of electrons
all right now for statement 2 so let me
write this this is statement 1 statement
statement 1 that is my procedure right
over there now for statement two
statement 1 test I guess I could say and
then statement to test statement 2
test I think you guys get the idea by
this point but I'm just writing it out
because you would have to if you were
taking this ap test I would say put
voltmeter I can lowercase voltmeter put
voltmeter in parallel with let me write
it out with bulb if measures voltage
drop voltage drop or I could say if and
only if so well I'll say if measured
voltage drop then how do they actually
phrase the statement see does the
electric potential energy of electrons
change then electric potential energy of
electron changes electric they call see
electric potential energy electron
changes then electric potential energy
of electrons
I don't normally write this much changes
otherwise does not if no voltage drop
then no change in potential energy if no
voltage drop voltage drop then no change
in potential energy electric potential
energy we could write potential energy
and there you go that is part a where
I've set up my neat diagram I measuring
the current entering and exiting the
light bulb and actually few view it from
the electrons point of view this one is
measuring electrons going in that
direction at this is electrons entering
electrons exiting but either way the
electrons per second would affect
current same current well then you have
the same electrons per second a
different current then you have
different electrons per second
exiting bulb and this measures the
electric potential energy across the
light bulb and if that is if you see a
if you actually measure a voltage here
then then that means that the potential
energy is is changing from one side of
the bulb to another and so I'll stop
there and then I will I will
well actually I think I answered part B
to explain how data from the experiment
you described can be used to answer
question one above explain how the data
from the experiment you described can be
used to answer question two above so
this is really Parts A and B so actually
let me write this down so this is a plus
B right over here we have the diagram
and if you're taking the test depending
on how your time pressure is you might
want to label this more but if you're
running out of time then you might not
have time to describe it in as much
detail